born and raised in Texas Jeb Bush moved
to Florida in 1980 the son and brother
of presidents he himself was governor of
the Sunshine State from 1999 to 2007
where he quickly became known as a
champion of school choice and fiscal
responsibility in 2016 he had an
unsuccessful run for president and he
now resides in Miami Dade County happily
retired from political life a
self-proclaimed old school conservative
with libertarian blood running through
his veins I talk to Bush in October for
a special issue of Reason devoted to All
Things Florida he told me the reasons he
believes more people are mov into
Florida than any other state what he
thinks of current governor Ronda santis
and leading Republican presidential
candidate Donald Trump his problems and
they are many with President Joe Biden
and what's so special about immigration
and
America Governor Jeb Bush thanks for
talking to reason honor to be with you
Nick um so let's start with uh the
question of you know Florida has become
the fastest growing state in the country
what explains Florida's growth as a
destination for people wanting to move
there and live there and work
there uh I think Florida works pretty
good it's like whatever problems we have
pale by comparison to to other states
and I mean like if you no disrespect to
the Northeast but if you have business
up there like I do and you go and you
drive like you're G to get a broken back
basically trying to go from here to
there because the infrastructure is is
decayed the challenges are immense and
you come here and the roads the roads
are working we've got a lot of people on
them but uh fewer potholes things work
better and so it's for people that come
to visit they can kind of get uh the
Allure of Florida and then typically
what happens happens is they visit a few
times and then they say all right I'm
making the making the jump when did you
move there what year 1980 1980 and
Florida has at least since the I mean in
the post-war era but definitely in the
60s 7s 80s 90s and continuing just saw
really kind of explosive growth Texas
has also where you grew up you went
school at University of Texas
Austin uh I hope that they lose in
whatever you know football games that
they have coming up this season I'm
rooting for Ohio State be that as it may
both Texas and and Florida uh two states
that have become reliably red are now
kind of kicking the butt of New York and
California the these four states are the
four most populous states in the country
um is there something going on where the
general kind of
political system in Florida and Texas is
being revealed as better than the ones
that are in place in California and New
York uh Miami day County where I live
has two and a half million people it's a
big Urban teeming Place full of uh
diversity it has a 1.4% unemployment
rate I mean effectively it used to be
Nick we're old enough to Remember full
employment was like at 4% oh yeah so I
mean people are half the people have two
jobs I guess I don't know it's like it's
it's full of
opportunities um the tax code matters
obviously for people uh with more wealth
for sure we don't have income tax we
have smaller governments the impulse
isn't to like to try to tax your way to
Prosperity or regulate your way to
prosperity it's not a perfect place for
sure I get nervous about bragging too
much because the minute you stop
challenging basic assumptions about the
role of government is your atrophy sets
in and you know government kind of just
starts filling the seams and uh so we've
had a great run because we've had a
period of limited government uh and and
we don't try to like micromanage
people's lives and as long as we do that
and we stay focused on the important
long-term things and I would say make
making sure infrastructure stays up with
the growth making sure our natural
systems are protected which is a
important uh conservative principle in
my mind is you know could rape and
pillage the the uh the swamplands around
South Florida and you would have a hell
of a problem going forward so investing
in these long-term things which they
don't do in California New York because
they've made you know 20 30 years ago
they made obligations to the unions and
obligations in the here and now that
that creates a government that is far
bigger than it is in Texas or in Florida
how talk a bit more about conservation
efforts or the environment in Florida is
a big deal because you know it's a state
that is surrounded by water on you know
three sides right um and environmental
regulations tend to be um looked to
scance by conservatives uh they're also
expensive how how when you were Governor
how did you manage to keep environmental
regulations in place that preserve you
know the ecosystem you know the kind of
natural infrastructure but also didn't
overwhelm the ability to kind of create
jobs and and build you know space for
more people to move
there so uh we had a land purchasing
program that that identified the
pristine areas the watersheds that were
important to
protect uh that otherwise could
eventually become developed um and we we
either did conservation easements or we
purchased them we purchased or did
conservation
easements um we did3 billion dollar
probably four billion dollar uh during
during eight
years um directly Appropriations from
the legislature and a Florida forever
program where we took dock stamp
revenues basically the growth of the
state was taxed um through transfer
taxes during you know when you when you
sell or buy a piece of property and that
money was bonded to buy these properties
and it was called Florida forever and
that's a tradition that is bipartisan
but Republicans have been just as
aggressive uh in protecting these
long-term things because Florida would
be a crappy place to live if if we
develop uh along the watersheds first
and secondly it would make it really
hard to we don't have dams I mean we the
tallest place in Florida is 10 m south
of Alabama um we have 55 inches of
rainfall yeah and it all goes out to
tide basically so protecting these
systems is also good to be able to
continue to grow to to have water
capacity for Urban Development for for
agriculture and for the natural systems
so you know
conservation uh low taxes low business
regulation allows the economy to grow
and for people to be able to move there
what about the cultural side and that
that may not be the right word but I'm
when you look at the history of Florida
you know through the 60s it was part of
the Confederacy it was a segregated
State um you know somehow in the 70s uh
and Beyond it really moved into a modern
phase um how you know you you don't get
the sense that Floridians in the 1950s
were kind of the hustling entrepreneurs
that you see there now how did the
culture change and how important is that
to the Vitality of of a place to
live that's a great question my my
gubernatorial hero um was uh Governor
Collins wasn't a republican I don't
think there were any Republicans back
1950s he his first before he got El
before he got inaugurated he took a
trade mission to Latin America I mean
like who does that um not in the 1950s
uh and he fought against
segregation uh successive Governors
worked hard on economic development and
the population itself changed we became
you were totally right I mean people
down here in Miami when I when I came
they were calling it Mi like a southern
town so the combination of influx of
immigrants and influx of other people of
people from other parts of the country
and pretty Progressive leadership that
says we're not going to be successful
unless we you know you can be respectful
of the past of the Southern Heritage for
sure but uh I think the aspiration and I
certainly felt this way when I was
governor uh we're not a we're not a
region we're you know we're we're a
region in ourselves we're a mega State
and we need to behave like that um and
so uh one of the challenges we face is I
always got really pissed off when people
said you know I asked said where you
from I did it as a matter of habit and
they would say I'm from Pennsylvania I
said no no you're not you're from
Florida like come on be proud of the
place and I think that's kind of caught
on now I think people are actually very
proud to live here what um what's the
role of Education the the South as a
region kind of historically lagged in
education for a variety of reasons
Florida particularly under your uh
guidance really started setting a path
for you know the state funding um you
know not just education in general but
more choice and things like that you
know when we're talking you know we're
talking roads we're talking you know the
environment we're talking tax regulation
what about
education so this is this is what is not
discussed in in detail but like call it
say Chicago or you know Washington DC or
New York they spend spend $25,000 per
student you divide it all in the state
of New York the average per pupil
spending is about 30 grand a year
average State I was trying to be kind
how much of that is basically to pay for
the sins of the past pension obligations
that were negotiated healthc care
benefits for retirees how much is that
is actually going to the classroom
compare that to Florida where we you
know
are people in the past didn't do that in
fact you know when I was governor we
eliminated tenure we moved to uh an
option for a defined contribution plan
rather than defined benefit the pension
was is you know effectively well funded
compared to other states so you can
focus on the here and now and education
so our funding while it's less than the
national average um in terms of
classroom education I think is pretty
good and then we didn't just accept the
status quo we graded schools you know
and if schools were failing parents
would given options we eliminated social
promotion we created real robust
accountability we put a real focus on
Early Childhood literacy and we created
the most expansive public and private
parental Choice programs in the country
and that result is parents like here in
Miami day third or fourth largest school
district in the country 70% of the
parents the students parents decide
where their kids go to school think of
that I mean do you think I mean would
Los Angeles be better would Chicago be
better would New York be better under
that system hell yeah it would and and
so we've seen uh particularly with in
the lower income communities kids of
color kids with learning disabilities
we're top five in the country based on
the nation's report card there's still a
long way to go and then I then I would
add Nick um over I'm not talking about
the US News and World Report kind of
input driven rankings of colleges but
the more quanti you know the more
qualitative rankings University of
Florida is like top two or three Public
University in the country in terms of
entrance rates in terms of research in
terms of graduation rates in terms of
and it's free it's it's I mean don't get
Bernie Sanders upset about this but we
actually have uh bright future
scholarships so anybody that U qualifies
for that does not pay tuition and if you
do pay tuition it's about the lowest
tuition in the country maybe second
lowest in the country um so that's a
pretty good deal it's about the best
deal a family will ever get from
government irrespective of what state
they're eventually going to live in
right to be able to get a high quality
education so yeah all the
way yeah we have Universal prek what is
your sense of excuse me legislation
under the current governor Ronda santis
things like the stop woke act which you
know affect higher education as well as
K through 12 um and it it does does not
seem to be you know
particularly uh you know good for
academic freedom as well as freedom of
expression does that concern
you um it it concerns me a little bit um
I do think that if you're in fourth
grade or below that you you shouldn't be
accessing any ISS you know any
discussion of sexual
orientation unless your parents choose
to put you in a school where that's part
of the curriculum of course or or or if
your parent decides that you know after
school they can talk all they want about
that stuff I I'm not sure there'd be
like 1% of parents that would talk to a
kindergarten about this stuff I'm
thinking more of the you know higher
education because it is you're right
that Florida you know both University of
Florida Florida State certainly uh
University of Central Florida which is
now I think the largest institution in
the country um that's you know where
you're hearing people's you know
including faculty saying like I I can't
teach history under under this kind of
law I don't know I mean U look the
governor has uh as a master at virtue
signaling but so is the left I mean
we're in this virtue signaling food
fight I'm not sure the substance of the
the uh the bills that have passed have
created a dangerous place for speech I'm
not I'm not certain that that's the case
but I do think we have to be vigilant
about it it's one thing to say you can't
like impose these woke cultural values
on
everybody uh which I think is an issue
it's the other thing to say well
therefore we're going to impose our
values on um on everybody I I just I'm
I'm a you know I'm kind of an old school
uh conservative with libertarian blood
running through my veins and I I think
what we need to find is an environment
where we let people have an honest
discourse and if you believe you know
you believe what I believe you you
should have the you know a right to
discuss it and defend it and you should
allow other people the people that may
disagree with aren't the enemy they just
might be wrong and have a open dialogue
and I think our universities are pretty
good at that compared to other places
where we're seeing right now you know if
you're a Jewish kid going to one of
these Elite schools you're in danger I
mean that is ridiculous uh what's going
on so both sides uh have these impulses
that I think I'm uncomfortable with but
I would say the left is probably uh much
worse than the right uh we talked about
uh Florida being like the destination
for places it has the fifth uh highest
foreign born population as a percentage
of its residents in the country uh in
2022 more Americans move from other
states to Florida than any other state
in terms of net
migration uh my question is do
immigrants whether they're from outside
the country country or within the
country do they bring their values with
them this is what you hear a lot you
know Venezuelans coming into Florida are
going to turn it into you know Venezuela
of the north um New Yorkers Californians
going to Cal to Florida are going to
bring those governmental systems with
them do you do you believe that um or do
you think that's
off uh I think it's off I I I it's
always been a concern you know that all
these uh whoever from wherever they come
and they bring their values but I mean
think about it if someone's leaving
California and there's quite a few
Californians that have moved here I've
War to Texas and to Arizona but if
they're leaving they're leaving for a
reason uh they're probably leaving
because they want Economic Opportunity
for themselves and their families or
they're tired of being taxed to death
you know so one of the interesting uh
data points in terms of migration is I
think
25% of all of the income that has moved
from one state to the other has moved to
Florida
25% so these are high income people that
are moving here because you know like if
you live in New York City U the next
budget shortfall which is probably next
month the first idea the second idea the
third idea is tax the rich well there's
probably you know 1% of the taxpayers
probably pay 40% of the the budget these
guys are really stupid to do this but
they keep doing it and so You' got you
know people migrate for different
reasons the immigrants from other
countries there is no evidence that Ugo
Chavez is going to do well in uh yeah
Miami I promise right I mean obviously
the Cubans who moved from Cuba you know
they love castra that's really what they
were coming to America for right um what
do you exactly so these but the point I
wanted to make because you know in Miami
day County which I keep talking about
because I live here
65% maybe 70% of the people in this
County were born outside the country
there is nothing like it in the rest of
the country Los Angeles May Come
Close and these are patriotic people
there is no woke I mean people don't
walk around with pronouns in their you
know calling cards around here um they
believe in Freedom they've left
oppressive regimes they're concerned
when they see policies that try to
impose um you know a heavy hand of
government um it's chaotic it's diverse
it's fun yeah um and and it's it adds a
dynamism that is really remarkable it's
the principal reason why I moved in 1980
and it's even better now yeah what do
you make though of the anti-immigrant
sentiments that you know are definitely
on the rise throughout the country but
people like Ronda santis uh people like
Donald Trump who you know I'm talking to
you from New York um I think you Florida
has to claim Donald Trump as you know as
aidian now and we'll talk about the
Florida man Concept in a bit but you
know what do you make of the
anti-immigrant sentiment which seems to
be rising throughout the country but
also in places like Florida where people
are streaming in um where does it come
from and how do you how do you manage
it well first I think there's a
legitimate concern about an open
border and whether you are
pro-immigration like I am or a IST and
want to close legal immigration even um
great countries all countries should
have the right to control their border
and this this is current Administration
the previous administration had great
rhetoric didn't do much did did a little
bit better but this Administration has
been um you know the the convergence of
bad policy and bad politics uh you want
to stay away from that intersection and
he manages to sit right in the center of
it with his border policy so there's a
lot of anger and frustration for that um
I'm not sure that's that's um a
xenophobic feeling at all I think it's a
legitimate concern about um the this
wave of people taking advantage of a
broken immigration system you know these
people come and they claim a they say
they have a well-founded fear of
persecution and ultimately 5% will have
a legitimate claim and they should be
allowed in 95% don't after four years
because the courts are all clogged up
and then they get their Deport ation
order and the likelihood of them showing
up for that is Slim or not how would you
how would you address that then because
there you know and there is that
separate issue of legal immigration
which people like Donald Trump has said
he you know when he was president he
wanted to reduce legal immigration he
did independ actually did yeah um you
know but how how do you deal with the
border and then how do you kind of
disconnect the two so that people aren't
thinking immigration is by definition a
criminal act
almost you you Chang the Asylum laws to
require people to make their claims
outside the country uh the Trump
Administration for a while did that but
they they may not have had the legal
basis to do it by executive order you
need to change the law um that would be
one element controlling the Border using
technology and uh and and a wall where
appropriate it's not appropriate across
every mile but it certainly uh um would
would would provide U some security
there use e verify properly um create a
guest worker program where it's easy to
come to work legally than it is to come
illegally right um create a uh narrow
them people that are coming by family
reunification we're the only country in
the world that has spouse and minor
children like all other countries but
also adult siblings and adult parents so
we've had you know since
1965 um majority of people coming are
coming through that family reunification
a lot of them are not as productive as
as they could be if you narrowed that
and expanded the number of people coming
that aren't taking jobs away but are
creating jobs use the Canada model um
deal with the you know the dreamers that
through no Faults of their own are here
and give them a path say deal with them
yeah you mean offer them a way to be
here legally yeah I mean come on you
these are like 25y old young men and
women now they have no next to the
country that their parents brought them
in I mean let's be realistic about it
and then for the 10 to 12 million people
that are probably 13 now a million
people here um uh illegally give them a
path to to to uh residency not not
citizenship which I think would be the
fair thing to do now that's a I wrote a
book about this and those were the ideas
and those ideas I wrote that in 2013 and
it still applies because the political
class up in DC want to use use this both
sides want to use this as a political
wedge issue yeah what you know you uh
and your brother were in in many ways
the you know you're kind of like a dying
breed of pro-immigration and
pro-immigrant
Republicans um what has happened to the
Republican party that it has veered so
far away from seemingly having anything
good to say about
immigrants I don't know I mean uh
I think there are a lot of Republicans
that are pro-immigrant per se um but our
look the reason why people are angry is
the systems that we've relied on the
institutions we've relied on haven't
worked we can't enforce our existing
laws as it relates to immigration people
get upset I think it's legitimate um you
have the Avalanche of fentel coming into
our country and the tragedy that that
brings you have um I mean all I mean
think of an what what institution is is
working the way it should in the 21st
century and so there is a deep
resentment that the elites are doing
quite well you know like I'm I'm blessed
I got a healthy family an intact
family um I'm in I'm in business in a
way that I can add value you know I got
a great life and a lot of other people
do but there are a ton of people they're
one paycheck away from real hardship and
the system hasn't been working for a lot
of those folks and so you try to find
scapegoats and whether you like
President Trump or not I'm not a big fan
um he has tapped into that anger better
than any politician in the last
generation of time and it explains I
think and that
connection um explains his um pretty
strong hold on the Republican party
right now does that hold worry you going
into 20124 and you know to keep it kind
of in Florida you know you have Trump
hulled up in maral Lago you have D
santis who in many ways has you know he
courted Trump uh he's very trump-like in
many of his policies even if he's not
doing very well is there a future for a
Republican party that is really centered
around a kind of trump personality and
agenda which seems to be you know we got
to close the borders we got to you know
exert more control over everyday life
things like
that I think uh the way you deal with
the legitimate resentment that people
feel and the anger and The Angst that
they feel is to fix the things that are
broken and if that happens I think
people a person a candidate or
a a message that is more hopeful and
optimistic about the future rather than
one that's about grievance and anger um
could Prevail but right now uh that's
not the case and so it's you know it's
hard to see how in 2024 there'll be any
kind of SE change on that but but Nick I
mean think about it if you compare the
United States to other countries we
we're the only developed country that
could rebuild our demographic pyramid
that could be young and dynamic again we
lead the world in all sorts of
Innovations and Technologies we have a
pretty good neighborhood if we control
the border Mexico is not going to invade
us the Canadians you know you gotta keep
your eye on them but generally
yeah you know we got a huge border with
them maybe they'll
uh but they're on10th our size and then
we got the Atlantic and Pacific I mean
Europe is confronted with all sorts of
of historical and current challenges
that make us look really peaceful
China's demography is a disaster their
economy is a disaster the debt loads
they have are very similar to ours but
we can renew ourselves yeah um but it
requires fixing some really important
things and I would hope that the
conservative side of politics would be
the ones that offer those up because the
other guys are going to offer you know
more whatever Green New Deals and
infrastructure business where you
mandate if you're you know you have to
have a left-handed Albanian in your uh
cabinet or your board of directors or
just all this weird stuff that the
progressive love to impose on people
it's gonna it's not going to look good
um if we get back in the game I'm I'm
you know I'm excited for my
grandchildren right now I worry about it
what um do you think uh the Republican
party you know a decade ago or 20 years
ago um it did seem to be leaning look
when it looked to the Future it seemed
to be leaning libertarian of saying you
know government should be doing a few
essential things and doing them well
that got derailed you know by Wars it
got derailed by administrative bloat and
a lot of other things but now when you
look at the Republican party you it's
rare to see anybody have nobody has a
Libertarian bone in the body they're not
not talking about spending they're not
talking about reducing the size and
scope of government is a you know does
the Republican Party need to go
libertarian in order to kind of win the
future I I look I'm out of politics uh I
guess I'm so old school that I think
believing in Freedom and limited
government and entrepreneurial
capitalism uh rather than picking
winners and losers and doing it through
government is the path forward I've
always believed it I haven't changed my
mind
um I don't know but maybe the indication
indicator is is the subscription base of
reason is it up or down yeah well we're
reaching more people you know so maybe
that's good but well keep it up because
you got keep working it because it
doesn't look like it's having much
effect in DC right now you're absolutely
right conservatives you know when Jim
Jordan trying to buy votes literally to
buy votes to to get become a the speaker
says well I'll G I'll guarantee you
we'll get rid of the salt um you know
bring back the salt deduction for high
income people in high you know high in
big govern local income or state and
local tax deduction which was the one
cap on it with yeah that was great that
feds exactly and you know it was uh why
should people in Florida pay for the the
burdensome nature of the government in
New Jersey or New York and so he was
willing to buy that buy a handful of
votes I guess uh by apparently I've read
that in the midst of his negotiations
well a conservative would never do that
like so these are this is a different
version these are populists maybe not
conservatives they're certainly not
libertarian um I mean the only thing
that I would say in the defense of the
Republican party it's not as bad as the
Democratic party but it's certainly not
like no one wakes up in a cold sled
saying the deficit is too high yeah what
is so bad about the Democratic party
under Joe Biden at this
point um proposing what a$6 trillion
doll uh spending plan for money and with
money we didn't don't have and only
getting two trillion or something you
know these are big
numbers um his using the regulatory
state to um to carry out his
agenda uh I have a business that we're
involved in that that helps that
refurbishes Transformers well there's
now a new law a new
rule that's uh going through the process
that would basically eliminate the
supply chain of Transformers which is
kind of important if you want to
Electrify the the U transportation
system and Harden the grid and expand I
mean think of all the gpus that are
necessary for data processing and you
know this all requires Transformers and
another it's a policy that deals deals
with uh um using materials that we can't
we we don't make uh to be part of the
Transformer manufacturing process that
will have less carbon emissions so it's
it's this multitude of agendas that are
imposed that make it harder and harder
for the United States to compete yeah
that troubles me did you ever think I
mean as you were you know Rising through
the ranks and whatnot that you know
after the 2000 that you would be seeing
the rise of anti-free trade people on
the Democratic side and the Republican
side uh and people being anti-immigrant
uh you know
again in 2000 I didn't see it no I
didn't see it I didn't see it when I was
governor either um no this is this is
this has happened um maybe an increment
is not discernable to the naked eye it's
kind of happened over time like all
things do I mean that that's we're
living we're not in a linear world we
we're in a cyclical world and the cycle
right now uh is people are very
comfortable with uh advocating
Government Solutions to everything yeah
now another reason why I love Florida is
get the contagion hasn't spread to other
places I mean we're AAA Bond rated and
we don't have an income tax we uh under
governor Scott uh I think they reduced
the debt the state debt by 70% there was
no debt issued in the eight years that
Rick Scott was governor
um What other state did that in a high
growth situation I certainly didn't
Charlie Chris didn't do it I I don't
know if Governor Dan sanis has but um
there is a way to show that you can you
know pursue limited government ideas and
balance the budget create reserves deal
with a you know hurricanes all the time
um have a don't have a bloated
government um and and help people and
put the people that are most vulnerable
in the front of the line that that that
philosophy still exists here um you uh
one of the ways or one of the things
that's kind of unique about Florida is
the special tax districts which have
become you know kind of a big thing uh
you know uh between fights between
Disney and Dan santis and whatnot could
you explain quickly what those are and
are you in favor of maintaining them
because how how many are there in
Florida I mean there are hundreds
there's a ton of them some of them are
very limited in their scope water
districts and others um they're they're
Regional in some cases uh they some of
them have taxing Powers uh and you know
the proper thing to do is hold them to
account um Sunset them review them the
case of REI Creek it is pretty unique I
fact it's the only one of its kind which
is in effect the quazi County
government and it was uh it was pretty
smart to do in whatever 1960 because
there were two counties where Disney's
property existed and this was a way to
assure that the quality that Disney had
in terms of governance infrastructure
could be maintained and frankly the
infrastructure in inside re Creek is
world class no I mean it's not I'm not
kidding like best infrastructure in the
United States so there was a reason for
doing it I remember when I was governor
we had 68 chales silver chales that were
part of the SS
Florida uh you know group of silverware
for for hosting people I guess and the
68th was Rey Creek um was kind of part
of who we were uh I I I don't know I'm
I'm uncomfortable with changing that I
think it's important to to have
accountability around it and the
governor's task the board that he's
replaced the Disney Executives I guess
are are supposed to be doing that as
long as it's not punitive I mean but it
was right I mean he explicitly said he
was going after Disney because they
crossed him on a couple of laws or
initiatives
it yes uh it's it's it was punitive in
terms of rhetoric for sure is it
punitive in terms of the operations of
Disney and Central Florida I don't know
I'm not sure uh but I hope it isn't
because uh 880,000 employees
and billions of dollars of investment
it's it's a principal reason why we
don't have an income tax in our state uh
I mean 32 million people last time I
checked go to go to the Disney
properties it's an economic driver of
success for a ton of other people not
just the employees of Disney so uh I
think you need to be respectful of that
and if the young ends out in Southern
California are woke okay fine I
mean the Disney CEO should have should
have like slapped him across the face
and said you know grow up the fact that
he didn't um created this kind of
vulnerability for Disney and and I think
the this passage of the law was more
than appropriate but um you go beyond
you know the
rhetorical slapping Disney in the face
uh where you're actually hurting the
Enterprise you're you're hurting Florida
no and I don't know I don't think I
think the the rule on that the there is
it's not clear whether that's happened
or not would you uh talk a little bit
that excel in Ed which you're the head
of um why you know this is a a a group
that really pushes um you know kind of
personalized backpack funding a variety
of school reforms that really give
parents and students more control over
how they get educated or how they
educate themselves um what motivated you
to focus on education and education
choice I think uh I mean I've been
interested in education parental choice
and education since gosh we founded uh
flans for educational choice in 1990 Tom
feny uh who was a be became the Speaker
of the House in Florida and myself and
Billy ni was
a person in Fort Myers we created this
and the first event we did was a
barbecue with Paulie Williams who was
the uh sponsor of the legislation in
Wisconsin go that far back yeah
yeah local uh councilwoman who been a
member of the Black Panther Party and
whatnot a real you know ear mover and
Shaker in school
choice she she she sponsored the bill
Tommy Thompson supported it and passed
it into law and uh I kind of yearned for
those days where on at least on the one
thing that a conservative and a liberal
would agree on they would pause and
actually act on it that's what they did
um so I I just think in a in a world
where you want more parental engagement
and you want them to be informed
consumers of the most important service
that their family will ever have which
is a quality education they're going to
be a better Arbiter of what's right for
their kids and a better judge of what
the best school is and Florida was you
know basically parents were locked out
and so apart from advocating I had I got
a chance to act on that and successive
Governors and legislatures have followed
up after that so one of the lessons in
policy world is success is never final
reforms never complete Governor Dan
sanis gets great credit with the
legislature passing a full-blown I'm not
kidding education savings account and
hundreds of thousands of students today
but literally at you know 10 years from
now it could be over a million students
will be going to the school that their
parents choose Mii Dade right now gosh
60% of of of students are going to a
school public or private that their
parents choose and miy dve
school system is considered the best
Urban School District in the country
there's not it's not a surprise for me
that if you Empower parents you're going
to get a diversity of offerings and if
you have accountability around that and
parents understand where their kids
stand you're going to get a great result
and you know for the elite
families everything's gonna be fine yeah
you know because they're they're the
first teachers of their kids they tutor
their kids they pay for you know they
pay for tutors they do all this stuff to
protect their kids and help them learn
but what about the 90% of families that
don't have that luxury you better make
sure your schools are vibrant are
focused on the future make sure kids can
read by third grade access to algebra uh
in in the middle schools have career
orientation where appropriate in high
school and um and have just high
expectations because kids are smarter
than we give them credit for and you
know so Excel and Ed takes these ideas
takes them on the road we were the
Florida literacy efforts were emulated
in Miss Mississippi and mississipp had
the greatest gains in Early Education
based on the NP you know the nation's
report card it was 50th out of 50 and it
went um it's it's now it's the only
state in the pandemic era that actually
seeing significant gains why because
they they had high expectations for kids
mostly minority kids mostly low-income
kids they train teachers on science of
reading not the bogus other approach the
majority of teachers were taught and uh
they ended social promotion in third
grade and it it can work I mean and now
the so-called Mississippi Miracle it's
really not a miracle it's hard work by
teachers that are trained appropriately
where resources are given to let them
let them soar do you think there's a
contradiction uh among conservative
education reformers where on the one
hand there's an emphasis on Choice which
you know various points people you know
liberals or people on the left talked
about it but that's kind of faded
they're very locked into a kind of
centralized status quo you know old
model um but conservatives who say on
the one hand they want to give parents
more and more choice but then people
like Ronda santis who say okay but
certain books certain curricula certain
things are off the table um is that a
contradiction um that needs to be kind
of explored and and blown up
yeah but show me the books that were
banned so-called book you know banned
the this the books in question were
removed from elementary school to age
appropriate places is that appropriate
yeah I think it is
um
look there's there's so much
misinformation these days um and people
a you know they aggregate their news in
ways that uh validates their beliefs
they're not learning anything they're
just getting their views validated I
think I heard you talk about that on uh
Megan Kelly or some probably it's yeah
you know something that confirms your
beliefs right a program or a show that
confirms what you already
know yeah there is there is definitely
confirmation bias in all the information
we get and uh I mean I know the people
Manny Dias is the commissioner of
Education U I've talked to him about
this and the amount of heat uh that has
been generated I mean look govern to Sis
he's been a really effective governor
and I think he's done a fine job but he
controversial is all get out by Design
yeah you know what do you candidate Ron
candidate Ron wants to get wants to
wants the libs all fired up because that
is kind of the way we play politics now
Governor Ron if you look at actually
with the you know what's what's happened
and the implementation of it um it's a
little bit different and you know I I
like I like leadership and the the
Governor's Place because things can you
can move the needle there you know and
that's what that's what he's done and
Florida's a better place because he's
been an aggressive Governor what do you
think about uh his you know shipping or
or sending migrants to you know places
like New York City or Martha's Vineyard
and stuff like
that well that's a virtue signaling very
creative one yeah um it seems to have
gotten the attention of people and now
you have big City Mayors
that are saying the Biden
administration's got to get its act
together enforcing the Border had that
not had had Governor Abbott and Governor
Dan sanis and maybe other Governors not
done this they probably wouldn't have
gotten that attention do I do I am I
comfortable with you know people looking
who do know you know I'm not I'm not
concerned that about people crossing the
border like they're bad people at all if
I was in their circumstance would do the
exact same thing that doesn't make it
right uh we have broken immigration law
that's not enforced and uh these are you
know these these families um I have
sympathy for them for sure but the Biden
Administration should get its act
together and they ought to work with
Congress to fix the laws that are broken
and they ought to enforce the existing
laws in a much better way and they're
negligent on this and a lot of people
are suffering you think about the people
that don't make it to the Border because
believe uh that they can get in think of
the loss of life think of the uh amount
of money that the coyotes have gotten
the drug dealers have gotten you know
this is a disaster it's a humanitarian
disaster and the focus ought to be on
the Biden Administration their inability
to to follow the
law uh as a uh final question um the
concept of the Florida man you know a
you know a person it's usually a man it
can be a woman
uh you know doing incredibly insane
stupid things often while you know after
snorting whatever was around uh and
things like that has become ubiquitous
over the past decade what do you make of
the Florida man meme
um look it's uh it's probably not fair
but who cares it's funny yeah um we
should embrace it you know like we're
striving to have a disproportionate
number of candidates for the Darwin
Award each year and we should be very
proud of it yeah you want to run the
table we'll take I'll tell you what I'll
take the Florida man all the people
laughing at Florida because of that uh
I'll take our tax structure I'll take
our Environmental Policy I'll take our
education system I'll take our way of
life uh and um I'll be okay just a quick
follow up on that you know it's
interesting so Florida is now the third
most populous state
um you know the top four are California
Texas Florida and New York New York
California and Texas all have strong
kind of identities that people know you
know California was the dream New York
is New York City and the Hurley Burley
and all of that Texas uh where I sadly I
passed two years in Huntsville Texas so
uh that I don't talk about too much but
um you were in Huntsville by I was
living outside the prison so yeah I uh
wow but um Texas is its own you know its
own country its own region it has its
you know does Florida have an identity
or a culture that can you know Galvanize
the nation or can it become the next big
thing in kind of American
identity I I think it can but it's a
great question Nick because uh my
brother when he got elected I went to
his inaugural uration and same siiz
crowd as my Inauguration in
1998 not everything is bigger in Texas
but there were no American flags they
were all Texas Flags right hundreds of
them all around you know fast forward to
my inauguration there were
like there wasn't even a Florida flag on
top of the state capital there were
American flags though all over the place
uh but we don't have a I think we have a
emerging identity but it's not it's not
clear it's more Florida is a group of
regions in many ways um and South
Florida is very different than the
Panhandle it would be helpful to have a
sense of shared identity for the state
I've always advocated that I don't think
we've reached our full potential there
and by the way I'd kind of like that for
our own country what is the shared
identity that we have in our country now
we're we're tribal and we're broken
ourselves up in all these disparate
parts I mean Florida does mirror the
United States in that way in some
Fashions but it's a more positive U very
much so yeah positive place people are
proud to live in Jacksonville proud to
live in Tampa but they're not
necessarily that doesn't always
translate to Proud to live in Florida um
you know going back to the the concept
of a shared identity for America in our
history you know we've had various ones
including you know we were the the
Puritans and the pilgrims uh we were the
westward explorers we were a nation of
immigrants was certainly a huge one that
you know that I you know think about a
lot my all of my grandparents were
immigrants from Europe that ended
sometime around the end of the Cold War
it seems do you have like what is you
know do you have an idea of what a
cultural identity for America that is
inclusive enough so that you know
everybody who's here feels part of it
but also not so loose that it becomes
meaningless yeah I mean I think this
will sound like a cliche and that's sad
that it does but I would say the shared
identity should be that it doesn't
matter where you start in life it
doesn't matter where you were
born uh it doesn't it it what what
matters is that you have a chance to
rise up and that your hard work will be
rewarded and that you you know you'll be
part of the exceptionalism of our
country where people irrespective of
where they start in life have a chance
to to succeed and uh that's being
challenged like never before uh and a
lot of people don't believe that that's
the case anymore and so they resort to
more government or they resort to you
know Collective action rather than uh
pursuing their dreams as they see fit I
think America at its best is you know
crazy
chaotic uh two steps forward one step
back it's not planned out um the great
um you know the great businesses the
great ideas that will emerge in the
post-pandemic era I'm really excited
about um history's rep of examples of
this and at a time when we really need
that sense of shared identity I think
it's eroded to the point where it it it
maybe of all the things that trouble me
that's that and the fiscal deficit are
the two things that trouble me the most
all right we're going to leave it there
thank you so much for talking to reason
Governor Jeb Bush thanks
[Music]
Nick